[Musica]
Vi è mai capitato di vedere la vostra
immagine riflessa nello schermo spento
del vostro smartphone avete di recente
succede molto spesso perché ho
un'impostazione di risparmio energetico
per la quale dopo qualche secondo di
inattività lo schermo si blocca il
display diventa completamente nero e lì
all'interno di quello specchio in
proprio di quello specchio nero
mi rivedo per quello che sono realmente
se fino a qualche secondo prima stavo
accedendo alla dimensione virtuale
attraverso uno strumento
quello stesso dispositivo trasformato in
specchio mi racconta quello che sono
nella dimensione analogica un individuo
quasi sempre completamente Solo che
tiene in mano uno strumento Ecco c'è
qualcosa in questa scena che secondo me
racconta molto a fondo quelli che sono
le dinamiche della rivoluzione digitale
soprattutto quello che ci è successo a
tutti noi Da quando i social network
sono diventati un elemento così
importante per la nostra vita io Credo
abbiano costruito uno sconfinato
gigantesco enorme specchio nero entro
cui tutti noi depositiamo il nostro
riflesso
per capire però Questo ragionamento
bisogna cominciare dalle parole perché
lì dentro se nasconde un significato che
merita di essere approfondito per
esempio finora utilizzato due termini
come fossero due sinonimi display e
schermo laddove in realtà se andiamo un
po' a scavare ci rendiamo conto che
esprimono Due significati non sono
diversi ma diametralmente opposti
schermo e lapalissiano significa
qualcosa che blocca che fa scuro che fa
appunto schermo D'altra parte display
l'origine anglosassone e significa
mostrare cioè una contraddizione è
evidente eppure li prendiamo come
fossero la stessa identica cosa a queste
due parole bisogna aggiungere un altro
termine o meglio una locuzione che è
cruciale specchio nero che cos'è lo
specchio nero oggi Io credo sia lo
smartphone ma ha una storia questo
oggetto molto affascinante
a cominciare dalle società dalle culture
precolombiane lo specchio nero assume un
valore magico
nelle Americhe si trattava di una pietra
di ossidiana un materiale nero che
veniva levigato
Fino ad ottenere una superficie
riflettente e lì dentro i sacerdoti o
comunque le persone autorizzate a
compiere questo rito potevano
intravedere la dimensione delle divinità
era una soglia un portale che permetteva
di accedere ad un altrove già qui c'è
qualcosa che ci riporta al contemporaneo
a quello che facciamo con i nostri
schermi con i nostri display con il
nostro personalissimo specchio nero
accediamo ad un altrove e anche in
Europa nello stesso identico periodo
Degli Specchi neri di ossidiana delle
culture precolombiane anche in Europa
l'oggetto era magico lo specchio nero
veniva utilizzato da streghe e stregoni
per la divinazione di nuovo una soglia
uno strumento per accedere ad un altrove
in questo senso in una dimensione
temporalmente diversa rispetto a quello
in cui si trovavano
potenti di questo dispositivo magia
qualcosa di oscuro qualcosa che permette
di intravedere un altro spazio un
altrove che estende la realtà fino a
sconfinare in un qualcosa che la
trascende
qualche decennio più tardi Rimanendo in
Europa lo specchio nero dà oggetto
magico per intenderci all'epoca
dell'Inquisizione possedere uno specchio
nero era considerata una prova certa di
stregoneria e sul finire del Seicento
Quindi in realtà questa trasformazione
avviene nell'arco di qualche anno appena
lo specchio nero da oggetto magico
diventa dispositivo artistico e qui
entravo nel mio campo e lo specchio nero
è meglio conosciuto almeno negli addetti
ai lavori come specchio Cloud deve
questo nome ad un artista Claude Loren
che potremmo definire in modo un po'
improprio un vedutista quantomeno
all'epoca era molto molto famoso per i
suoi paesaggi che avevano una
caratteristica tecnica e stilistica
estremamente precisa lui saturava i
colori li rendeva vividi brillanti e
soprattutto era in grado di staccare le
figure che dominavano la scena dallo
sfondo il quale
l'ottava invece sfocato è qualcosa se ci
pensate che noi conosciamo benissimo che
ha a che fare con la fotografia e con la
cinematografia l'idea di imporre tutta
l'attenzione focale Sul soggetto e lo
sfondo invece perde di Potenza degrada
questa idea questa capacità questo stile
questa grammatica visiva all'epoca
piaceva tantissimo
e per fare in modo di somigliare
al lavoro di Lorraine degli Artisti
minori progettano uno strumento lo
specchio nero che si chiamerà appunto
poi specchio Cloud era un oggetto molto
piccolo perché doveva essere utilizzato
all'aperto per ritrarre le scene che
Lauren
erano state Ecco rese famose da Lorenzo
questa idea che possiamo chiamare con un
termine molto specifico pittoresche
per fare in modo di aderire a questo
codice quindi gli artisti progettano un
dispositivo uno specchio come ho detto
piccolo convesso dipinto di nero la
convessità creava un particolare gioco
di rifrazione per cui le figure al
centro della scena risultavano davvero
all'interno del riflesso staccate
rispetto allo sfondo e il colore nero
saturava nella rifrazione i colori della
scena
c'è un passaggio cruciale però gli
artisti non guardavano il paesaggio da
ritrarre ma lo osservavano all'interno
di un riflesso di fatto davano le spalle
a quello che avrebbero poi dipinto
creavano un filtro fra loro e la realtà
è quel filtro serviva per aderire ad un
linguaggio ad un codice che funzionava e
loro sapevano e pur di essere simili
allora n perché vendeva Non ci sono
altre spiegazioni perché vendeva perché
era pittoresco è piaceva pur di fare
questo mediavano la loro veduta e si
affidavano ad uno strumento è
esattamente quello che facciamo tutti
noi sui social network per due ragioni
La prima è che esiste all'interno di
ogni piattaforma una testualità
specifica abbiamo un certo numero di
caratteri da utilizzare per scrivere un
testo E questa cosa è codificata
predefinita le fotografie
un certo tipo di formato e dobbiamo
entrare all'interno di questa logica e
omologare i nostri contenuti esattamente
come gli artisti guardando il mondo
riflesso nello specchio mediavano la
loro vista e facevano in modo che
somigliasse a quello che per Lorenzo
invece era sensibilità personale
ma il passaggio più importante di tutti
e che in realtà noi Facciamo un'opera di
schermatura quando utilizziamo i social
e qui ritorna la parola schermo
Che significa nascondere escludere e se
ci pensate nel momento in cui
raccontiamo qualcosa sui social non
importa tanto ciò che mostriamo quanto
quello che decidiamo di escludere dalla
nostra narrazione
se esiste un certo grado di
consapevolezza il fatto che mi sembra
abbastanza banale evidente noi
raccontiamo e mostriamo agli altri le
cose di cui andiamo orgogliosi le cose
di cui siamo fieri e lasciamo fuori da
quel racconto a quell'opera di
narrazione perché è una scelta
arbitraria abbiamo il potere la facoltà
di riscrivere la nostra vita
estromettendo schermando tutto ciò che
non vogliamo mostrare agli altri quando
però osserviamo le vite degli altri
utenti Questa consapevolezza viene meno
Allora sembrano esistenze perfette
esistenze prive di sbandature errori
Anzi angosce preoccupazioni tutto quello
che caratterizza qualunque vita ma
schermandola gli altri come noi in primo
luogo riusciamo a creare un'opera di
narrazione più precisa più puntuale
È ovvio che poi nel confronto che
facciamo con un'opera narrativa ci
sentiamo in difetto siamo sempre
costantemente
in affanno perché guardiamo una
narrazione non riusciamo a ficcarcelo
nella testa stiamo riscrivendo la nostra
vita e quando guardiamo quella degli
altri andiamo a competere perché poi è
questo il problema
con delle opere d'arte
con delle finzioni
E allora perché stiamo sui social perché
in realtà sui social siamo bene Siamo
incredibilmente bene e qui rientra
l'altra parola display mostrare che cosa
mostrano i social un mondo
cucito su misura un riflesso
troviamo le nostre idee confermate
possiamo creare Community aggregazione
tutto questo è positivo è molto
difficile spesso trovare nella vita vera
delle persone che condividono i nostri
interessi in un modo magari anche molto
profondo sui social è più semplice ma
chiudiamo la visione che abbiamo nel
mondo all'interno di una stanza che
riflette all'infinito la stessa Eco e ci
radicalizziamo diventiamo convinti che
il mondo tutto il mondo corrisponda in
modo così preciso e puntuale a quella
che è la nostra idea di realtà che viene
riflessa all'interno di uno specchio
cucito su misura per l'utente l'utente
finale ora
fino a qui sembra abbia fatto un
discorso estremamente apocalittico
sembra che i social e in generale la
rivoluzione digitale tecnologica siano
il problema del nostro tempo che siano
distruggendo la cultura la società che
siano l'elemento il discrimine della
distruzione morale della nostra civiltà
non è così vi assicuro che io credo
fermamente che la rivoluzione
tecnologica e digitale più di qualunque
altra trasformazione che è avvenuta nel
corso della storia Abbia fornito a
ciascuno di noi uno degli strumenti se
non lo strumento più potente dell'intera
storia dell'umanità
ma per rendere quello strumento Qualcosa
di davvero prezioso per ciascuno di noi
dobbiamo riappropriarci della
trasparenza
e rendere lo specchio una finestra Se il
mondo riflesso dai social network è
qualcosa di così cucito su misura per
l'utente finale che fa un'esperienza
sempre sempre sempre più radicale della
sua visione
riuscire
ad uscire dal riflesso di nuovo rendere
l'oggetto la tecnologia lo strumento
trasparente ci permette di intravedere
quella che è la realtà la vita è un
viaggio Noi siamo costantemente in
divenire
è uno specchio non riesce a restituire
questa corsa questa sensazione di
mutamento
Voi immaginatevi invece di osservare un
finestrino da un treno in corsa quello
che vedete Quel paesaggio che cambia è
il mondo e il mondo sta quello vero
quell'orizzonte che potete magari un
giorno decidere di calpestare
calpestarlo sul serio Sta al di là di
una soglia il vetro separa dal mondo ma
viceversa estende il nostro sguardo e
questa è una cosa meravigliosa perché
permette di fare una cosa cruciale
contaminare
ritrovare qualcosa che ci sorprende
riscoprire una scintilla una fiamma
qualcosa che ci permette di rimettere in
discussione tutto quello che credevamo
essere la realtà
Ecco fare questo è qualcosa di molto
molto simile a ciò che crea qualunque
tipo di forma d'arte l'estetica nasce
non per risolvere non per offrire delle
risposte ma per insinuare il dubbio per
creare delle domande e la domanda la
curiosità La sorpresa è il motore del
cambiamento
dell'evoluzione dobbiamo ritornare a
sorprenderci
e per farlo Trasformare lo specchio lo
specchio nero che crea un riflesso
distorto parziale cucito su misura
che scherma al mondo che lo chiude e
mostra soltanto quello che noi pensiamo
essere l'idea del mondo
dobbiamo trasformare questo oggetto in
una finestra perché
nella trasparenza esiste la possibilità
di sorprendere noi stessi in conclusione
uno specchio non può sorprenderci una
finestra invece sì
Grazie